of all the people in the world you're
very likely to be the one who creates
the agi system
um that achieves human level
intelligence and goes beyond it so if
you got a chance and very well you could
be the person that goes into the room
with the system and have a conversation
maybe you only get to ask one question
if you do
what question would you ask her
i would probably ask um what is the true
nature of reality i think that's the
question i don't know if i'd understand
the answer because maybe it would be 42
or something like that but um that's the
question i would ask
and then there'll be a deep sigh from
the systems like all right how do i
explain
exactly all right let me i don't have
time
to explain uh maybe i'll draw you a
picture that it is
i mean how do you even begin
um
to answer that question
well i think it would um what would you
what would you think the answer could
possibly look like i think it could it
could start looking like uh
uh more fundamental explanations of
physics would be the beginning you know
more careful specification of that
taking you walking us through by the
hand as to what one would do to maybe
prove those things out maybe giving you
glimpses of
what things you totally missed in the
physics of today
exactly just here here's glimpses of no
like there's a much
uh
a much more elaborate world or a much
simpler world or something
um
a much deeper maybe simpler explanation
yes of things right than the standard
model of physics which we know doesn't
work but we still keep adding to
so um and and that's how i think the
beginning of an explanation would look
and it would start encompassing many of
the mysteries that we have wondered
about for thousands of years like you
know consciousness
uh life and gravity all of these things
yeah giving us a glimpses of
explanations for those things yes yeah
well um
demonstrate one of the special
human beings in this giant puzzle of
ours and it's a huge honor that you
would take a pause from the bigger
puzzle to solve this small puzzle of a
conversation with me today it's truly an
honor and a pleasure thank you i really
enjoyed it thanks
you